from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Little Caesars in the US and the
UK this is Street Wars
Little Caesars in the U.S sells hot and
ready pizzas in one size 14 inches
closer to 13 and a half I'll let it
slide though in the UK Little Caesar's
Hot and Ready pizzas only come in one
size 12 inches that means that the
surface area of a UK Little Caesar's
Pizza is 113.1 square inches the surface
area of a U.S Little Caesars Pizza is
153.94 square inches that makes the
pizza 36 percent larger than the UK's
now we can get crazy bread in the UK and
we ordered it from our Little Caesars
but unfortunately they forgot it if they
remember your crazy bread it looks like
you get four pieces with an order
according to the website too bad for the
UK but the us we did get our crazy bread
in an order of crazy bread comes with
eight sticks eight crazy sticks it
wouldn't of course be a order of crazy
red without the crazy sauce to add
insult to injury they gave us just the
crazy sauce but without the bread let's
wear anyway to see how much we get a
side of crazy sauce in the UK weighs 7
grams so 159 grams
whoa it's so crazy it's fine I wouldn't
call this house crazy misunderstood
maybe but it feels like the sauce kind
of has it under control this is a very
mild mannered well thought out
well-measured sauce another item
available in both countries is cheese
bread I'll say on the medium rare side
of cooked 7.5 inches across and 5.5
inches wide I would like to note that in
the U.S our cheese bread is called
Italian cheese bread ooh that's almost
exactly nine inches seven inches if you
want to get a small Peach at a Little
Caesar's just got the Italian cheese
bread inside of sauce some assembly
required
here are all the Little Caesars menu
items in the UK that you won't find in
the US here is all of the Little Caesars
menu items you can get in the US that
you won't find in the UK before we talk
about some of the default Pizza options
we'll talk about some of the
customization options you get in the UK
that you guys can't change in the US for
example over here we can sub out the
tomato sauce base for barbecue sauce or
Peri Peri sauce I think the Peri Peri
sauce is kind of a nod to the UK's
obsession with Peri-Peri you guys know
how much we love our Nando's I think
Little Caesars are trying to get in on
that as well Nando's just dropped to
their knees in Tesco just like oh my God
no the Peri-Peri option doesn't stop
there because you can also add piri pre
seasoning to the crust of your pizza at
all seasons the U.S customizations for
the crust round which I guess is regular
but we also have thin crust stuffed
crust Detroit style deep dish and
stuffed crust deep dish for bake we also
do a well done cheese you can get
obviously regular cheese but no cheese
or light cheese sauce same thing light
normal extra no sauce now let's talk
about some of the pizza options in the
UK you won't find on the menu in the US
here we have the barbecue chicken pizza
if you stare at this thing for too long
you will be lured into a hypnotic trance
the barbecue sauce is very sweet and
kind of becomes the main thing that you
can taste if that's your thing do it not
really mine over this way we have the
spicy Peri Peri
OD the Peri-Peri is quite gentle just
like a little bit of heat maybe but to
call that like a spicy Peri Peri I think
they've oversold the spicy and they've
also kind of oversold the Peri-Peri our
next Pizza is this one it's called the
cuatro what they've done is take a pizza
and divide it into fours and then top
those individually so you have two
slices of Margarita two slices of
pepperoni two slices chicken and
mushroom and two slices of peppers
tomatoes and sweet corn all right this
says SC pepperoni stuffed crust
pepperoni I mean this looks like pretty
generous with the pepperoni it's a bit
more neon colored than I'd like the
crust of course is stuffed with
mozzarella cheese yeah yeah not bad I
also try
sorry stuff gross people just kind of
don't care about it something newer to
the Little Caesars menu here in the US
is something called slice and sticks
which is half Pizza half breadsticks for
the consumer that wants a little variety
just them by themselves don't want to
get a whole pizza whole thing of sticks
I want to point out that slicing sticks
come in what I think is this aka the
classic we also get bacon slice and
sticks and jalapeno slicing sticks throw
on your grass skirts ladies and
gentlemen we're going to Hawaii this is
the Hula Hawaiian which of course is
bacon and pineapple
I think pineapple and Peach is perfectly
fine this hawaiian's not very good but
it deformation thin crust thin crust
pepperoni it's pretty good if you want
to pay the exact same price for
literally half the pizza so far for
Little Caesars the pepperonis winning
across the board Little Caesars got me
through some Financial rough patches
don't be too hard on them but I mean
some of them like oh yeah my early 20s
great five meat Feast count with me here
pepperoni ham sausage hamburger bacon
and yeah I think it's like a seasoned
beef I don't like when they go ham and
pork or two different Meats I know
they're two different but it's kind of
like they're pretty close or it should
be five meats two animals the seasoned
ground beef or sausage looks a lot like
Mouse turds making this incredibly
unappetizing
you're trying too hard with this one
then we have a few Deluxe options in the
UK starting with a pepperoni Deluxe if
you're wondering what makes this Deluxe
when compared to a standard pepperoni
they just take some extra pepperoni and
add it to the pizza and then sprinkle it
with granapadano cheese I will say like
it doesn't look slightly more deluxe
than the rest let's see if it tastes
Deluxe
it might just be a placebo effect but it
does kind of taste like the best one
I've had so far I don't know if I'd
stretch to like deluxe as an adjective
but slightly better for sure maybe just
rename it the slightly better pepperoni
something that here in the US Our Little
Caesars has I've never heard of this
before and I don't know exactly what
they're they're doing a series of pizzas
two pizzas called and this is all one
word extra most bestest the extra most
bestest cheese and pepperoni is this
just rebranding the plain cheese in the
plain what makes this extra most bestest
all right let's find it together it's an
upgrade take on their classic pepperoni
pizza that offers 80 percent more
pepperoni uses 25 more cheese okay so
more cheese and more pepperoni wait a
second wait a second wait a second
because someone Graphics take a
screenshot of that well we'll compare
this to there's there's a pepperoni
that's coming up that has a lot more on
here so next up is another Deluxe option
the margarita Deluxe just as like a
linguistic note in the UK if you see a
cheese and tomato pizza on the menu it's
almost always referred to as a margarita
everyone knows what that means it's a
slightly more traditional Italian way of
saying cheese and tomato whereas in
America it seems like you guys all just
have to say cheese pizza or you don't
really understand what you're getting to
turn this Margarita into a deluxe
version it seems like all they've really
done is added I think some herbs and
then some chopped up pieces of actual
tomato
all I really have to say about most of
these is that they're fine our final
Deluxe pizza exclusive is the mushroom
Deluxe again it looks like a fairly
standard mushroom pizza with I think the
herbs again and the granapadano
sprinkled around the edge it's also
funny that they call this one a mushroom
Deluxe pizza because there isn't
actually a standard Mushroom on the menu
so I guess if you uh like mushrooms on
your pizza you're being forced into
having the deluxe fancy version this
is the old world
fancoroni pepperoni go wrong now that's
pepperoni let's go the cups oh yeah now
remember when a minute ago that we just
saw that was the the extra best mostest
whatever the hell it's called yes yes
this is pretty good I will say the dough
on all these pizzas are a lot spongier
I'm hoping that that is a choice to make
it spongier and not that they just
didn't cook these through I'll find out
in a couple hours of the regular round
pizzas last and certainly least veggie
as before mentioned version of pizza you
can get here in the US we have a Detroit
style deep dish pizza at Little Caesars
you can get the ultimate Supreme the
veggie the pepperoni the three meats
Hawaiian and just regular cheese I went
with the pepperoni because I feel that's
classic Detroit style hmm Detroit let us
know in the comments how they did true
Detroit style puts the sauce or a little
bit of sauce on top they did not so it
just looks like a really thick Pizza
love our bread in this country
I would suggest against selling this in
Detroit so what we have here is the UK
only Pizza what we've done is take all
of the customization options you can
only find in the UK and combine them
onto one pizza so what this pizza has is
the Peri-Peri sauce base a barbecue
sauce drizzle Peri-Peri chicken regular
chicken red onions sweet corn and
tomatoes
honestly that's not terrible far from
the worst UK only creation that we've
ever met the Perry Source base seems to
just be tomato sauce with like a bit of
Perry seasoning kind of mixed into it so
you still get a bit of the sweetness
from the tomato and a very gentle warmth
from that the barbecue sauce is kind of
the dominant flavor again but as far as
UK only pizzas go it's not bad a segment
that usually we haven't done this in
forever it feels like a USA only that's
right this is a pizza you can only get
in the United States of America add a
Little Caesars of all the many USA only
options we went with a well done pizza
with a stuffed crust extra sauce light
cheese old world pepperoni pineapple and
black olives oh man
the extra sauce I think is what really
oh God the extra sauce is what really
ruin this because now it's just all
sliding off
it's really bad it's really bad because
it's like falling apart and also we got
this separately so this was actually
just came out of the oven it's like
really hot then we're on to the sides we
have two exclusives in the UK now while
we didn't get any of the crazy bread at
least we got the crazy Puffs they take
the dough they form it into a kind of
cupcake muffin shape which is then
filled with some tomato sauce some
cheese and pepperoni
to the grease like dripping out of that
as soon as I bit him they're not bad
they're on like a mid-level of the crazy
scale and we can also get veggie crazy
puff it's the same cheese and sauce base
but then instead of the pepperoni
they've added corn peppers and onion we
also have stuffed crazy bread remember
that crazy bread from earlier now it's
stuffed what the [__]
this is like a giant mozzarella stick is
it really melted
oh man remarkably Bland avoid the
Caesar's got Wings oven roasted barbecue
and buffalo I'm starting to get a
headache I can't for the life of me
pinpoint what is making me suddenly so
nauseous we have a couple of exclusive
sauces in the UK which means it's time
for sauce talk we have three sources in
the UK that you won't find on an
American menu which is garlic and herb
when you order Domino's it comes by
default with a garlic and herb dip in
the UK people go crazy for that dip
people really love it so a few other
places have tried to kind of jump on
that bandwagon and this is their version
we then have a Peri-Peri sauce and
finally we have a ketchup on the menu
I'm questioning anybody who eats pizza
with ketchup I'm gonna be honest and we
don't really even have any sides on the
menu that go with ketchup so the garlic
and herb is defeating me Leon help
thank you
it's got quite a harsh taste actually
surprisingly harsh try the Peri Peri
so the thing is peripiri has a very
distinct flavor it's a specific type of
chili all I'm really getting from this
is just like chili pepper heat we have
ketchup can't quite put my finger on it
I'm gonna literally put my finger on it
it's got almost more of like a tomato
soup flavor to it which I don't hate
after my Preamble about how much I do
not think ketchup should go with any of
these pizzas it actually ended up being
my favorite of these three sauces I
think that's more of a comment on the
other two not being very nice rather
than the ketchup being good you have a
variety of four exclusive delicious
dipping sauces butter garlic flavor
buffalo ranch cheesy jalapeno and just
making the wrench if for seasons in the
UK also has one dessert option you won't
find in the US chocolate chip cookies
so we got desserts cookie dough brownies
one is Twix pieces you know those m m
Minis
very very sweet kind of weird actually
finally let's talk about drinks in the
UK Little Caesars carries Coca-Cola
branded drinks including obviously
Coca-Cola but then also things like
Monster Energy and Oasis which is a bit
of a British classic comes another
Citrus Punch or summer fruits it's kind
of like a diluted fruit juice refreshing
finally I can have some to drink they
had Coke products we got Pepsi products
oh you know the classic Pepsi log root
beer Mountain Dew and Starry it's the
new one it's what replaced Sierra Mist
R.I.P Sierra Mist thank God
yeah that's like exactly what seven
updates like they invented seven up
great job guys
unfortunately Little Caesars in the UK
doesn't give us a full nutritional
breakdown only calories a hot and ready
cheese pizza in the UK is 1 700 calories
that's 85 of your recommended daily
allowance a hot and ready U.S cheese
pizza is 1950 calories that's 97.5 of
your recommended daily intake also the
sodium good Lord 160 of your recommended
daily intake the most calorific Pizza in
the UK is this three meat treat a whole
one of these contains 1910 calories or
95.5 of your daily allowance we also
have the three meat treat but ours is
2870 calories that's 9060 calories more
than the UK version and ours is 143.5 of
your daily calories you're not going to
believe this the three meat treat isn't
our biggest calorie pie that award goes
to oddly enough this the pepperoni and
cheese stuffed crust pizza this whole
thing 3 300 40 calories that's 167
percent of your daily calorie intake and
of course the sodium the sodium
380 your recommended daily sodium intake
so the pizza's cut in eight slices so
one slice contains 1094 milligrams of
sodium which is almost half of your
daily amount in just one slice rip my
kidneys
a hot and ready Margarita or pepperoni
in the UK will cost you five pounds
which at the time of recording this is
six dollars and four cents a Little
Caesar's hand ready pizza has become a
contentious Topic in the US in recent
years forever this was just five dollars
but in 2022 they raised the price for
the first time in nearly 25 years price
can vary depending on your location but
where I am here in Southern California a
hot ready cheese pizza is now 6.49 or 5
pounds 40. our most expensive pizzas are
the ultimate Supreme spicy Peri-Peri
barbecue chicken and three meat treat
which will all cost you 10 pounds this
was my first time trying Little Caesars
pizza because currently there is only
one of them in the whole UK it's in
chellaston just near Derby having now
tried it and also with the context of
the price I think I'm fairly confident
in saying this is a pretty low rung
Pizza it is very rare to find anything
of this size four or five pounds in the
UK when you come to pizzas but in kind
of return for that you're not getting
the best quality I think in terms of my
taste of pizza power rankings for the UK
the this would be sitting fairly low but
for five pounds it's kind of hard to
complain because that is quite cheap I
don't know how do you feel about it Joe
when researching for this video I looked
it up and I was surprised to find out
and you might be surprised as well to
learn this Little Caesars is the third
biggest pizza chain in America totally
surprised Little Caesars recently became
the official pizza at the NFL what I
always thought this is me talking here
Little Caesars was always the cheapest
option also the quality was
never that good so I was surprised to
learn that this pizza is a still around
B very popular and see after this video
and not that bad I dogged in Little
Caesars for a while but I mean I've had
worse I've been asked by my producer to
wipe up the crumbs one thing Little
Caesars didn't provide were napkins
that's okay let me wipe my mouth real
quick
this video
sponsored by Domino's
at two Brute